[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاده الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياد
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من رام الله
الرئيس الفلسطيني
اما هذه الصور فمن طهران بعد تغريده
لمستشار الرئيس الاوكراني ميخائيل بدوليك
عن هجوم بطائرات مسيره استهدف منشات
عسكريه في ايران الخارجيه الايرانيه
اعتبرت موقفه بدلتك غريبه ومنحازا واستدعت
القائمه بالاعمال الاخرانيه
من مقر الامم المتحده بنيويورك التي صدرت
منها ادانه الامين العام للمنظمه الامميه
للتفجير الانتحاري الذي وقع في مسجد في
باكستان واسفر عن مقتل اكثر من 60 شخصا
واصابه اكثر من مئه وخمسين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
عقب محادثاته بلنكن يدعو الى تهدئه بشكل
عاجل ويشدد على انه لا بديل عن حل
الدولتين ويحذر من ان الابتعاد عنه سيقوض
امن اسرائيل وسلطه الفلسطينيه تطالب
واشنطن والمجتمع الدولي بوضع اليه ملزمه
لحمايه الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات الهجوم
الايراني يؤكد للجزيره ان اسرائيل مسؤول
عن الهجوم وريترياه يؤكد عزم اسرائيل
القيامه
لمنع طهران من امتلاك سلاح النوويه وروسيا
تصف الهجوه بالاستفزازه وتحذر من تداعياته
على السلام والاستقرار في المنطقه
في ادنى نسبه تصويت في تونس منذ الثوره
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات في تونس تقول ان
نسبه المشاركه في الجوله الثانيه للاقتراع
البرلماني بلغت احد عشر في المئه وسط
دعوات بتوحيد صفوف المعارضه من اجل رحيل
قيس سعيد وتنظيم انتخابات مبكرا
في ظل تكثيف الدعم العسكري الغربي
لاوكرانيا
الدنمارك لدعم اوكرانيا بالدبابات
بلاده لاوكرانيا بالدبابات امر غير مستعد
وطولندا تؤكد ان ارسال مقاتله اف 16 الى
كياب سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع دول النيته
وبشكل الخاص مع الولايات المتحده
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على بنصتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم التداعيات
المحتمله لجوله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو بلانكين التي يلتقي فيها مسؤولين
فلسطينيين واسرائيليين على واقع تصعيد
اسرائيليين في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وكذلك
تدهور امني في الايام الاخيره باستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي بما يتعلق بفرص نجاح جوله
بلانكين في خفض التصعيدي الاسرائيلي 12 في
المئه قالوا ان هناك فرصا كبيره لنجاح
جوله بلانكين بينما قال 24% ان الفرصى
محدوده وتوقع 64% بعدم وجود فرص اطلاقا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروح انا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقاءنا
على منصه الرقم يتجدد يوميا ويتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا وكذلك دوليا
وتتابعون ايضا في الحصاد هذه الليله
يوم دام في في شاور غربيه باكستان اكثر من
60 قتيلا في تفجير الانتحاري استهدف مسجدا
قرب مقر للشرطه
[موسيقى]
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه على
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
لوقف التصعيد مؤكدا على ضروره الحفاظ على
الوضع القائم في الاماكن المقدسه في القدس
جاء ذلك في مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي في القدس في هذه الاثناء
اعتبرت الحكومه الفلسطينيه ان الاجراءات
والتهديدات التي تطلقها اسرائيل تهدف الى
تقويض السلطه الفلسطينيه وكسره اراده
الفلسطيني
على وقت الصيد امنيا خطير وصل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي الى تل ابيب في زياره
مقررات سلفا تشمل اسرائيل والاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله
زيارته بلقاء رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي حيث
دانا عمليتي القدس وتجاهل ما خلفته عمليات
جيش الاحتلال من شهداء وجرحى فلسطينيين
وبينما اكد بلانك تمسك الاداره الامريكيه
برؤيه الدولتين تجاهل نتنياهو الالتزام في
هذا السياق وتحدث عن توسيع دائره السلام
مع دول عربيه في المنطقه
ستكون تاريخيا
السلام لكن هذا ليس بديلا عن يعني مع
الفلسطينيين الرئيس ما زال مقتنعا بان حل
الدولتين افضل الطرق لذلك الابتعاد عن هذه
الرؤيه يؤثر على الامن المستدامه
الاسرائيل وعلى الطرفين اتخاذ خطوات لوقف
التصعيد
يا تبرينكن والضفه الغربيه المحتله ما
زالت لملم جراحه بعد عمليات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في جنينه ونابلس وغيرهما
35 شهيدا منذ بدايه العام واجراءات
انتقاميه يمارسها الاحتلال بهدم منازل
الفلسطينيين في القدس المحتله لا تبقي
للقياده الفلسطينيه الى مطالبه الضيف
الامريكي بموقف حازم يلجم تصعيد الاحتلال
وانفلات المستوطنين
واعتداءاتهم على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين
المطلوب من الاداره الامريكيه ممارسه
الضغط حقيقي على الحكومه الاسرائيليه لوقف
جميع اشكال التصعيد وفي مقدمه ذلك الحصار
الظالم على قطاع غزه والاجتياحات والقتل
خارج القانون
ومجزره هدم المنازل وعمليات اسرع وتهويد
القدس وايضا همم الوقف التام لجميع
الانشطه الاستيطانيه
لكن على طاوله الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه مشروع استطني ضخم في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله يشمل بناء الاف الوحدات
الاستيطانيه الجديده ويبدو انها اثرت
تاجيل اعلانه الان مخافه ان يخلق ازمه
دبلوماسيه في خضامن زياره للمنطقه ليس على
اجنده محادثات
او خريطه طريق لانهاء الصراع فالظروف ولا
تبدو مواتيه لاي تحرك من هذا القبل اما
مساعيه لخفض حده التوتر فيبدو انها ستصطدم
بواقع الميداني يتجه نحو المزيد من
التصعيد
الجزيره القدس
ليه البحث في هذه الزياره معي من واشنطن
ريتشارد الخاص السابق للرئيس بيل كلينتون
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط وكذلك مع من الناصره
الدكتور محمود يزبك استاذ الدراسات الشرق
اوسطيه في جامعه حيفا اهلا بكم من واشنطن
السيد جوت تايم زياره لبليكن تم التحضير
لها سابقا بشكل
مكثف وفي النهايه عندما وصل اصبح عنوانه
الاساسي هو الوصول الى تهدئه ولو مؤقته
وبالتالي كيف ترى لمهمه بلانكن في هذه
الجوله
عنوان
ان يعيد التاكيد على الموقف الامريكي
الدعم لاسرائيل كدوله ديمقراطيه وليس
كدوله يهوديه كان هناك بعض المخاوف
المرتبطه ببعض التصريحات التي اطلقها
السيد نتنياهو والتي عبرت عن رؤيته عن
الحكومه وهي تختلف عن نوع ديمقراطيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن على اي
حال السيد بلانكن اراد ان يشدد على دعم
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل واعرب عن
تعازيه بشان الهجوم الذي استهدف من خلاله
ناس يصلون في الكنيس وهو امر لم نراه منذ
فتره طويله في الوقت نفسه اراد ان يحث كلى
طرفين في به المرحله
لخفض العنف وخفض التصعيد
اي شيء يمكن ان يؤدي الى العنف لا ياتي
بالفائده لا للاسرائيليين ولا للفلسطينيين
اسرائيل لا تواد ان تفقد المزيد من
الارواح والامر السيان بالنسبه الى
الفلسطينيين ونتحدث هنا عن الضفه الغربيه
وهناك حدود مع اسرائيل اذا ما تم تشديد
الاجراءات على الحدود هذا الامر يصعب حياه
الالاف من الفلسطينيين الذين يعملون في
اسرائيل وبالتالي من مصلحه
الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيين ان يخفضوا
التصعيد الدكتور محمود همم يزبك في ظل
الحسابات الاسرائيليه بتقديرك في ما قد
ينجح بلانكن في هذه الجوله وفيما قد يفشل
يعني عمليه
نجح حتى الان يمكن وانا اقولها يعني
بحصل او بسخريه اعاده مبلغ بعض الملايين
من الدولارات التي سرقتها اسرائيل قبل
اسبوعين من ميزانيه السلطه الفلسطينيه من
الضرائب التي فرضتها العائده والسلطه
الفلسطينيه والتي سلقها مصر المستوطنين
في البارح على ما تم الاعلان عنه
بمناسبه قدوم لينكن تم اعاده هذه الاموال
السلطه الفلسطينيه لكن من زار الضفه
الغربيه في اليوم الفائت ما انا كنت
بزياره مثل هذه الى الضفه الغربيه وكنت في
مدينه اريحا استغرقنا اكثر من ثلاث ساعات
للدخول الى الى اريحا بمعنى انه الحصان
المفروض على مدن الضفه الغربيه وخاصه
ومدينه مثل ريحه التي يعني مدينه هادئه
يعني في هنا همم ظلم كامل ويقع على الناس
في الحياه اليوميه وهذا ما تفعله اسرائيل
السؤال الكبير المطروحه عن الساحه وانا
اعتقد انه بلانكن لن يستطيع ان يفعل شيء
في هذا الموضوع وهو انه هل يستطيع ايقاف
البرنامج الاسرائيلي للتصعيد الامن ضد
الفلسطينيين وتمغيث حياه الفلسطينيين
اليوميه هل سيفعل ذلك طبعا لن يفعل ذلك
ولكن من ناحيه يعني هو كل ما يريده ويفعل
ويسعى اليه الضغط غدا على السلطه
الفلسطينيه همم انه اعاده التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل وبمعنى انه هذه الزياره
بالنهايه كما ارادها نتنياهو وارادته في
هذا الاسرائيليه يعني وضعها في سياق الاخر
وليس السياق الفلسطيني واذا ما ان نظرنا
الى حيثيات
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي كان اليوم ما بينكيو
رايت انه كلما تحدث ابن يمكن عن الوضع ليه
مباشره قامنه الياهو بنقل الحديث عن الوضع
الايراني بمعنى انه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
حتى على الملا هي لا تقبل التدخل الامريكي
لتغيير او تخفيف الضغط الحاصل في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه على الفلسطينيه وتنقيص حياتهم
اليوميه نعم سيد
الفلسطينيون يقولون للاداره الامريكيه
الحاليه انتم حتى لم توفوا
بوعودكم للجانب الفلسطيني سواء ما تعلق
منها بالقنصليه الفلسطينيه في واشنطن او
ما تعلق منها بكتب منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه او بتعلق من هذه الكثير من
الوعود التي قدمت من قبل هذه الاداره
وبالتالي ماذا سيقدم في هذه الجوله في ظل
هذا الوضع الامني الصعب
الاداره لم تنتهي ايام بعد وبالتالي لا
يمكننا ان نستثنى احتمال ان يفيا الرئيس
المقدمه بالنسبه الى الحضور الفلسطيني
رفيع المستوى في واشنطن لا اعتقد
صدفه ان اسرائيل لم تستخدم القوه العسكريه
في الضفه الغربيه في هذه المره في استجابه
او في رد
للمذبحه التي تعرض لها المصلون في الكنيس
في
القدس لقد استمعنا الى التقارير تشير الى
ان اعضاء في حكومه نتنياهو يرفعون الصوت
ويحثون الحكومه لكي تتخذ اجراءات صارمه
وهجوميه وعدوانيه
لا اعتقد ان اداره
جدا تدعم هذه المطالب ترى انها مؤديه ولكن
لا نتحدث عن صدفه هنا بلانكين في الجلوس
في القدس عفوا وهذا اللقاء مع نتنياهو ادى
باسرائيل الى التراجع قليلا بنسبه الى
منسوب القوه التي يمكن ان يستخدم ضد
الفلسطينيين وبالتالي هذه هذه نقطه مهمه
الدكتور محمود يزبك فيما يتعلق هل هو فقط
لوجود بلينكر في المنطقه مثل المعرفتك
بالداخل الاسرائيلي والحسابات داخل هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
هنا يعني مساله استعمال ال- ال- القوه هل
هي مساله مؤقته ام فعلا نجحت الاداره في
هذا المصعد
لا اعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه نجحت او
ستنجح في هذه المساله انه تخفيض او يعني
ثني الحكومه الاسرائيليه عن استعمال القوه
ضد فلسطين لو كان هذا حقيقه على الاقل
راينا او سمعنا يعني اييي موقف امريكي
تجاه المذبحه التي قامت بها اسرائيل في
مخيم جنين قبل ايام قليله والتي ادت هذه
المذبحه الى ما رايناه في القدس في
العمليه التي حصلت في القدس حسب اعتقادك
لينكن والاداره الامريكيه تجاهلت تجاهل
كاملا ما حصل في ما يحصل ليس فقط ما حصل
في جنين ما يحصل في الضفه الغربيه يوميا
من اذلال اليوم للناس شكرا لذلك الاداره
الامريكيه انا لا اعتقد لديها اي اشاره اي
اشاره لاي حل مستقبلي او حتى لتخفيض يعني
بعد انتهاء زياره
لا يعني نحن كمراقبين لا يوجد لدينا لا
يوجد لدينا امل بتغيير الواقع الذي تغير
دكتور محمود يزبك استاذ الدراسات الشرق
اوسطيه في جامعه حيفا وكذلك لضيفي من
واشنطن ريتشارد جود ستيل المبعوث الخاص
السابق للرئيس ملكلينتون لمنطقه الشرق
الاوسط
اذا كانت الزياره وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطونيو بلانكن الى المنطقه تجيء في غمره
التصعيد المتواصل في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله فانها تاتي ايضا على خلفيه علاقه
يشبهها التوتر بين اداره الرئيس جوبيدن
وحكومه بنيامين ليتني ياهو الموصوفه
بالاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ اسرائيل
ليس السؤال الوحيد لكنه ربما الابرز يحمله
معه انطوني بريكن الى تل ابيب كيف التعامل
مع حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو تضع الزياره
الخاطبه لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي تحت
المجهر علاقه لا يداري احد توترها يبدو
لتلياهو معليا بتطوير العلاقه مع واشنطن
بسبب ملفات اقليميه بعينها لكن حكومه
في اسرائيل على الاطلاق لن تشاطر مقاربه
لذره الامريكيه للشان
الاقربطيه متمسكه بحل الدولتين وضروره
التواصل مع الجانب الفلسطيني ورافضه تمدد
الاستيطان
هناك ما قرره على مسامع الاسرائيليين
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جاك سولفان
حين زارهم ممهدا لزياره بلينكن
هذه الزياره الان على خلفيه تصعيد تدعو
واشنطن الى اسرائيل في احتوائه فهل ان
المسؤول الاربعه في واشنطن الذي يلتقي
اقطاب حكومه اسرائيل لاعتلافيه الجديده
سيستخدم نفوذ بلاده لتحقيق تلك الغايه
وباي لغه يحدث نتنياهو العائله الى الحكم
على راس حكومه يهيمن اليمين المتطرف ووجوه
الصهيونيه الدينيه على تركيبتها
تلك التي جرت تل ابيب مبكرا الى المواجهه
اذا انا عاشت خطه الاستيطان في الضفه
الغربيه
القائمه في المسجد الاقصى كما صعدت الموقف
على الارض حتى صار الشهر الاول من هذا
العام الاكثر دمويه في الضفه الغربيه منذ
عام 2015
35 شهيدا بينهم ثمانيه اطفال اضافه الى
سيده المسنه
وتوضح وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان الاصابات
التي سجلت على اجساد الشهداء اظهرت ان
اطلاق النار كان يتركز في الاجزاء العلويه
وغالبيتها في الراس
هكذا سقط شهداء في كل من رام الله والقدس
وجنين والخليل غير ابي محافظه جنين سجلت
العدد الاكبر من الشهداء منذ بدايه العام
الجاري بواقع 20 شهيده حتى عشيه الزياره
وصلت سلطات الاحتلال سياسه العنف والتنكيل
بالفلسطينيين متدرعه بالعمليات الفدائيه
التي استتبعها تصيدها
كبلتهم بعقوبات جماعيه اطلق لها العنان
مجلسها الامني المصغر في حين سهل منح
الاسرائيليين تراخيص اسلحه وعزز الاجراءات
الامنيه في المستوطنه من نتائج ذلك
السريعه احراق مستوطنين خلال الساعات
الاخيره عشرات المنازل والمركبات
الفلسطينيه والحقول الزراعيه
ليس سرا ان تلك الهجمات وغيرها تتم بغطاء
سياسي من المتطرفين في حكومه نتنياهو
واولائك يصعب كما يبدو على الاداره
الامريكيه ان تلتقي مع مشروعهم
ارحب هنا في الاستوديو بضيف يا دكتور عبد
الله استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت اهلا بك دكتور عبد الله يكاد يكون
منصوب التفاؤل في مهمه بلانكن منعدما هل
من مؤشرات ولو غير مباشره تقول ربما
بالعكس او انه ربما قد ينجح في شيء قد
ينجح في نقطه معه يعني
هذا مثل ان الادارات الامريكيه المتعاقبه
تاتي الى اسرائيل وتجاملهم وانا اليوم
كاتب مقال في القدس العربي والشر اليوم ان
مجاملات ومحابالات اداره اسرائيل ستغرقه
في رمالها في الداخل انفاضه وعنف وتصاعد
العنف وفي الخارج احتمال مواجه مع ايران
خاصه في استقبال
لينكن كان عمليه اسرائيليه ضد مستودع
اسلحه في اصفهان وتصعيد على الجبهه
الايرانيه الاقليميه وتصعيد في الداخل
باختيالات وبقتل وبقتحامات
عبد الله رغم ان تصريحات الوزير عن مساله
التمسك بحل الدولهتين الوضع القائم في
القدس ولقاء اخرى
عندما تقول خفض العنف يعني شنو العنف
العنف يعني الاسرائيليين بقوتهم الضاربه
المدره تعادل الشباب الفلسطينيين المقاوم
هذا عنف قاعد يعني في مقاومه وفي ارهاب
وفي احتلال وفي ولا هم لا يرفضون ان
يعترفوا بذلك ولا رئيس امريكي تجرا ان
ينتقد اسرائيل اعلنا يتكلمون كلاش يعني ما
نسميها تعابير مكرره وقف العنف والحفاظ
على حل الدوله انت عندك اكثر حكومه متطرفه
واقسى اليمين فاشين في حكومه نتنياهو
تجعله من الحمائم
نسف الكليه نحل الدولتين اللي هو يعني
معادله امريكا منذ ايام اوباما وقبل
اوباما وكيري يتكلمون عن حل الدولتين الحل
الدولتان اليوم هو ابعد ما يكون عن ما كان
عليه من 20 سنه عندما بداوا يتكلمون عن حل
الدوله عندك حكومه لا تعترف بحق الفلسطيني
بالوجود
عندك يعني بن غفير الذي يتكلم العرب
مكثف قد يكون يعني ربما مكثف جدا من قبل
هذه الاداره مستشعر الامن القومي سلوفان
ثم ايضا رئيس الاستخبارات برزوه اليوم
يحضر بلنك
وهذه الارضيه الفلسطينيه جزء اساسي منها
اهميه زياره بلانكن اليوم هو الضغط غدا في
رام الله على السلطه الفلسطينيه محمود
عباس لاعاده التنسيق الامني هذا الهم
الاول لهم يعلمون انه بدون التنسيق الامني
ستحدث مواجهات بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
والقوات الامنيه الفلسطينيه والجيش
الاسرائيلي لانهم بخبرونهم نحن قادمين الى
جنين فانتم اتخذوا اجراءاتكم حتى لا يصير
في اشتباك بين القوات الفلسطينيه والجيش
الاسرائيلي هذا هو الهم الرئيسي
من الفلسطيني
حتى هذه المساله لم تعد بيئه السلطه فقط
السلطه تتحكم في كل الوضع بدايه هناك
فصائل ثم ان العمليه الاخيره التي جرت في
القدس من نفذ نفذوها بشكل منعزل وبالتالي
المعطيات تختلف عن الارض
السلطه الفلسطينيه محرجه جدا مفلسه
الاموال الضرائب اللي المفروض تحول الى
السلطه الفلسطينيه تجمدها اسرائيل وضع
السلطه الفلسطينيه مه من يقوم بالعمليات
في جنين وفي القدس اللي قام بها الشعب
العلقم هذه كلها ليست من الفصائل
الفلسطينيه المعروفه سواء انفتح او الجبهه
الشعبيه او حماس او او الجهاد الاسلامي
يعني هذا هنيل جيل الجديد من الفلسطينيين
هو جيل لم يعد يهمه شيء يعني يعني لا
دايره من من الغريق من الموت فلهذا السبب
يجب ان تكون في مقاربه مختلفه كليا للاسف
الادارات الامريكيه ليست في مكان تواجه
اسرائيل برغم التطرف الحكومي الفاشل موجود
فيها همم
الادارات جميع
خاصههيوني وعندها انتخابات قادمه وعند
الريف قبل الجحز بالجمهود والقيادات الحزب
الجمهوري تدعم اسرائيل واذا اتى الشهر
القادم همم الى البيت الابيض واستمع مع
قيادات الكونجرس ما في ضغط حقيقي يلجم
العنف والتعنف والتطرف الصهيوني ليه ضد
الفلسطيني اذا في بالفعل شيء يمكن ملموس
يخرج توقف اسرائيل تدخلات واقتحامات لجنين
وفي القدس وهدم المنازل والعقاب الجماعي
يعني الان سيطردون اهلا وسيدمرون منزل
ويطردون اهل الشعب الذي قام بالعمليه التي
قتل سبع اسرائيليين يوم الخميس الماضي في
القدس يعني هذا العقاب الجماعي والتطرف
عند الحكومه الاسرائيليه والمواجهه مع
ايران يدفع المنطقه كلها الى حافه الهاويه
ليس فقط داخل اراضي الفلسطينيه ولكن
احتمال تصير ايضا الانتفاضه احتمال تصير
حرب على غزه وايضا مواجهه مع ايران سواء
في الجولان او عبر الجنوب لبنان او عبر
القيام بايضا هاكينج وقرصنه داخل ايران او
في اسرائيل نفسها فالمنطقه
تغليكن اتى وجدول زيارته ولم ياتي بسبب
هذه الفوضى او هذه بل هي مجرد
انت وذكرتك عبد القادر اتى صدفا شنو سوى
بعد صارت العمليه اتى قبله بيلز شنو ما
صار شيء عشيه وصول لينكن قامت اسرائيل
بعمليه همم المسيارات وضربت في اصفهان
مستودع اسلحه ورفعت همم يعني حجم التوتر
عاليا جدا عشيه وصول هذه الرساله له ان
اليوم ايا يذهب قبل كده احنا مع اسرائيل
بمنع ايران من امتلاك سلاحنا ولا يمكن ان
تمنع اضاءت لك سلحناوي بالعمل العسكري بل
بالتفاوض واسرائيل ايضا تعرقل مصالح
امريكا سواء بيحلل دولتين او سبب توصل
لاتفاقنا مع ايران وتحولت الى الى عنصر
مهدد للامن والاستقرار اداره وايضا ترفض
ان تعترف بذلك الدكتور عبدالله
الكويت شكرا جزيلا لكم شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى تداعيات الهجوم في اصفهان فقد قال
مسؤول ايراني للجزيره انه هجوم اصفهان لم
يكن ناجحا وان كلام المصادر الاسرائيليه
مجرد دعايه للتعليم على الفشل حسابات
المسؤول الايراني ان المؤشرات الاوليه
تشير الى ضلوع اسرائيل في الهجوم ولابد من
متابعه تحقيقات وان ترجيحات تشير الى ان
المسير انطلقت من داخل ايران على مقربه من
الموقع المستهدف كما قال المسؤول الايراني
ان اسرائيل تعرف جيدا انها ستلتقي او
ستتلقى عفوا ردا وهذا ما حدث سابقا وان
هناك من يلعب بالنار ولا شك لدى ايران
بانه سيكون اول من سيحترقه في حاله قرر
اشاعه على حرب الاقليميه
اذا لا تزال المعلومات تتوارد عن الهجوم
على منشاه عسكريه تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الايرانيه في محافظه اصفهان وسط البلاد في
العرض التالي اتابعوا ابرز التحديثات بهذا
الشان
تتكشف معلومات جديده عن الهجوم على مقر
عسكري تابع لوزاره الدفاع الايرانيه في
اصفهان جنوب العاصمه طهران بعد التعرف على
الموقع الذي استهدف مساء السبت الماضي
بثلاثه مسيرات والواقع الى الشمال الغربي
من مدينه اصفهان تشير تقديرات الى ان مدى
مسيره يصل الى نحو 30 كلم
اطلاق التقديري في محيط مدينتي او محافظه
اسوان كما تشير معلومات الى ان الوزن
التقديري للقنبله المتفجره التي القتها
هذه المسيره في حدود خمسه كيلو جرامات بعض
المعلومات تفيد بان الموقع ذاته تعرض
لهجومي بالمسيرات قبل نحو اربعه اعوام ان
السلطات الايرانيه قامت في تحسين المكان
منذ ذلك الهدوء
هذا ووصفت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه الهجوم
على مصنع العسكريه في ايران بالاستفزازي
ونقلت وكاله رويترز عن الخارجيه الروسيه
قولها ان مثل هذه التصرفات المدمره قد
تكون لها تابعات غير متوقعه على السلام
والاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط وقد تثير
تصعيدا في وضع ملتهب بالفعل حسب تعبيرها
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطونيب لينك قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين ياهو ان سياسه حكومته
هي منعه ايران من الحصول على سلاح نوح
[موسيقى]
مشتركا على ان هذا النظام ينبغي ان لا
يملك اسلحه نوويه انخرطنا في مفاوضات جيده
تتعلق بالسياسات مشتركه للتصدي لهذا الخطر
اكرر امرا سمعتموني اقوله مره عديده
سياستنا وسياستكم ان نقوم بكل ما بوسع
اسرائيل من اجل منع ايران من امتلاك سلاح
النووي والسبل التي تساعدها على ذلك نحن
والولايات المتحده نعمل معا هذا بيحدداته
امر مهم لتحقيق هذا الهدف المشترك
تطبيق اما الحدود السوريه العراقيه شهدت
تطورات لافته تمثلت في قصف طائرات داخل
الاراضي السوريه لقوافل الشاحنات قادمه من
العراق هو رغم عدم تحديد هويه الطائرات
المهاجمه الا ان وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
ذكرت ان احدى الهجمات استهدفت قافله تابعه
لفصائل المسلحه ايرانيه
[موسيقى]
خلال 24 ساعه تقريبا شهدت الحدود السوريه
العراقيه هجومي منفصلين
ظهر الاثنين تحدثت مصادر امنيه عراقيه عن
قصف جوليا استهدف قافله مكونه
قصد كان منطقه السويعيه قرب مدينه
البوكمال السوريه
دخان من المكان ولم تذكر للمصادر حموله
الشاحنات ونتائج الاستهداف ونوعيه
الطائرات المهاجمه او تبعيتها غير بعيد
صادق قالت مصادر امنيه العراقيه ان اربعه
شاحنات استهدفت بصوارخ اطلقتها طائرات
مسيره في قريه الهري التابعه لمنطقه
المكمال عند الحدود السوريه العراقيه هذا
الاستهداف ايضا لم تاتي اي جهه على ذكر
نتائج
الاسرائيليه ذكرت ان القصف استاد تقع
قافله تابعتني من الشيعه ايرانيه كانت في
طريقها من العراق الى سوريا فهذه المنطقه
كمال السوري قابل لمعبر القائم العراقي
ويعدان جزء الرئيس من الطريق البري الرابط
بين ايران وسوريا مرورا بالاراضي العراقيه
انا من الدوحه الدكتوره فاطمه الصمادي
الباحثه الاولى في مركز الجزيره الدراسات
والخبيره في الشان اليه الدكتوره فاطمه
بالاضافه الى ما ادلبه المسؤول الايراني
للجزيره من معلومات
عن ردود الفعل في داخل ايران وكيف تقرا
وردت فعلها عن ما جرى بعد هذا الهاتف
بشكل الاساسي هناك بعض وجهات النظر تقول
بان هذا الهجوم في حقيقته كان محاوله
لاختبار
القدرات الدفاع الجوي الايراني بمعنى انه
محاوله لاختبار ما اذا كان بالامكان شان
هجوم او ساعه على ايران ولذلك فان التصدي
لهذه الهجمات وهمم تحيد واحده من الطائرات
واسقاطها سليمه همم كان يعني ادى رساله
جيده على هذا الصعيد همم من الناحيه
الايرانيه لكن في الوقت ذاته هناك قراءات
همم اخرى تقول بانه اذا كانت هذه
المسيارات انطلقت من داخل ايران لان همم
موقع اسمهان من حيث بعده عن الحدود يشير
الى ان هذه المسيرات همم اطلاقا داخل
الاراضي الايرانيه فذلك يعني
امني اا في ايران وهذا اا يعني توجيه
اللوم مجددا على الاجهزه الامنيه
الايرانيه همم على هذا الصعيد هناك جانب
يتعلق همم الرسائل الدبلوماسيه التي ارسلت
لايران ايضا همم في محاوله لاحياء لعمليه
التفاوضيه
ويتزامل ذلك مع الحديث عن مقترح جديد قدم
لايران
يتضمن همم نوع من الاتفاق الجزئي في حاله
عدم القدره على الخيام باحياء همم باتفاق
شامل يعيد احياء اتفاق النووي المجمده همم
هذا الاتفاق يقوم على نوع من تجميد همم
بعض جوانب البرنامج النووي الايراني خاصه
في مجال تخصيب اليوراني وفي المقابل ازاله
همم عدد من العقوبات او مجموعه من همم
العقوبات همم الحديث عن همم الخيال
الدبلوماسي بعد الصعيد الاوروبي وايضا اا
الرسائل الامريكيه بعد القول بان الاتفاق
النووي لم يعد اولويه من الولايات المتحده
لدى الولايات المتحده همم
الامريكيه ايضا همم الزياره المنتظره
لرئيس الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه همم
هذه كلها مجموعه من المعطيات تقول ان هذه
محاوله هذا الهجوم محاوله للتصعيد
في اطار التاثير على همم اي عمليه
دبلوماسيه همم قادمه
وبالمناسبه هذه واحده من الهجمات التي
تضاف الى هجمات كثيره همم جرت في في
المساحه التي تسمى بحرب الظل بين ايران
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه خاصه في عهد
نتنياهو 2000 يعني على مدى ما يقرب من عقد
من الزمان واكثر همم قليلا
دكتوره فاطمه الباحثه الاولى في مركز
الجزيره للدراسات والخبيره
[موسيقى]
الى تونس حيث قال رئيس هيئه العليا
المستقله للانتخابات في تونس الفاروق
معسكر ان نسبه الاقتراع العامه في الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه بلغت 11
و 14 في المئه وكان معسكر قد اقر يوم امس
بتداني نسبه المشاركه داعيا لنقاش
الموضوعين بشان ذلك من جانبه دعى رئيس
جبهه خلاص الوطني
عزوف قارب التطابق بين دوري الاقتراع
التشريعيين في تونس راى راى في المشهد
الانتخابي الحالي انه اذا حضر احد عشر في
المئه فقد غاب نحو 90 بالمئه من المدعوين
للتصويت ما يعد برايهم استفتاء عكسيا على
المسار الذي دعا اليه الرئيس قيس سعيد
معتبرا اياه تصحيح الثوره
التدني الحاد في المشاركه يسووا وفق رئيس
هيئه الخلاص الوطنيه احمد نجيب الشابي
الدعوه لرحيل الرئيس والتذكير بانتخابات
رئاسيه كخطوه الاولى لمسار الاصلاحيه كامل
المطالبه برحيل الرئيس جاءت ايضا على لسان
حركه النهضه معتبره ما سمته برلمان قيس
سعيد لا يعبر الا عن اقليه الاقليه وقال
بيان لخمسه احزاب تونسيه ان البرلمان
المنبثق عامه وصفتها بمهزاله الانتخابات
فاقد للشرعيه ولم يكون الا ديكورا بلا
تاثير
التراجع في المشاركه الذي جاء على نحو غير
مسبوق منذ الثوره التونسيه لم يكن الملمح
السلبي الوحيده في المشهد الانتخابي يوم
التاسع والعشرين من يناير بلبرزت الشكوى
من غياب الشفافيه المعززه بداها لمصداقيه
الانتخابات جهات حقوقيه تونسيه كمرصد شاهد
مراقبه الانتخابات وشبكه مراقبون تحدثت عن
منع مندوبها من دخول مكاتب الاقتراع وعن
حجب عدد من رؤساء تلك المكاتب للمعطيات
والارقام معتبرين ذلك سابقه خطيره من قبل
هيئه الانتخابات الهيئه نفسها وهي تعلن
يوم الاحد بسبب المشاركه اقرت بانها ضعيفه
ودعت لنقاش الموضوعي بشان ذلك بينما يسر
الرئيس التونسي على استكمال خريطه ووصم
منتقديها على طول الخط بالخيانه والفساد
والسعي للاسقاط الدوله
ورحب بضيفي هنا في الاستديو الدكتور
المهدي المبروك الوزير التونسيه السابق
واستاذ علم الاجتماع في الجامعه التونسيه
اهلا بك دكتور المهدي
وكان المشهد في تونس يوما بعد يوم يوحي
بمزيد من الانسداد والوصول الى حاله من
عدم الفهم ما الذي سيحدث في اليوم الذي
يليه هل الصوره بهذه القتامه
كنا ننتظر مثلا
[موسيقى]
السيد الرئيس الجمهوريه ان المسار الذي
دخلت فيه البلاد منذ يوم 25
تقريبا كل المؤشرات تدل ان الرئيس غير
قادر على ان يلتقط اللحظه ويقوم بمراجعات
من اجل همم تصحيح تصحيح هذا المسار الذي
همم دخلت في البلاد منذ اعلانيه اجراءات
25 والتي اعتقد انا في اعتقادي الخاص انه
انقلاب على الدستور ولا اعتقد ايضا ان
المعارضه استطاعت ان تغير من المعادله
السياسيه بما يدفع الرئيس الى مراجعه
الخيارات التي اقدمها اليها وبالتالي نحن
ندخل الان مرحله من العبث السياسي في مناخ
همم اقتصادي واجتماعي حاد طيب ودليل ذلك
يعني افتقاد المواد الغذائي يعني افتقاد
الادويه الى غيرك وايضا مسار السياسي يتسم
كما قلت برفض هذا المسار ولكن عجز
المعارضه عن تغيير المعادله لو افترضنا ان
الرئيس
اقتنع وغير والمعارضه اقتنعت وغيرت ماذا
تغير المعارضه وماذا يغير الرئيس حتى تمضي
تونس قدما اعتقد انه همم الرئيس عليه ان
يفهم تماما ان شرعايته بعد ذلك كل
الاختبارات التي صارت يعني الاستفتاء على
الدستور والتي كانت النسبه فيها ضعيفه ثم
ايضا تاكله التي شرعيه التي كان يزرعها
وتاكلت الشعبيه حتى مقارنه باستفتاح 25
جويلا الى حد الان يعني تقريبا في اقل من
بعض الاشهر يعني رئيس الجمهوريه يفقد
بسرعه همم
المعايير والمناخات التي حفت بها من
تقريبا 22% الى واحده يعني الى 11% يعني
نصف نصف همم الكتله الانتخابيه تبخر
التماما احنا اذن على الرئيس ان يفهم ان
هذا خساره الانفرادي لن يدفع الا الى
انهيار البلاد على المستوى السياسي
والاقتصادي والاجتماعي وايضا المعارضه
مطالبه ان تتوحد وان تقدم بديلا من اجل
ليس فقط يعني مراقبه الانقلاب ومراقبه هذا
التمشي الاحد والانفرادي انما اولا
الاتفاق على حزمه من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه العاجله جدا والاتفاق على
بديل اقتصادي
والسياسي بالدرجه الاولى لانه حتى
المعارضه لم تتفق الاعلى هل هذا وارد هل
هذا ممكن لمعطيات داخليه او معطيات دوليه
او اقليميه هل هذا وارد ما تتمناه الان ما
اتمناها او ما اتوقعه من باب الثمن نعم
انا في اعتقادي انا في اعتقادي ان همم
الاشهر القليله القادمه للاسف ستؤدي الى
المزيد من التعثر والمزيد من الاحتقان
السياسي والاقتصادي والاجتماعي الا اذا
استطاعت في مبادره وطنيه ان تجمع المجتمع
السياسي وان تجمع المجتمع المادي لان
المبادره التي الان يبدو ان لا يتم دغدغته
بالكثير من مشاعر التعاطف مع الاتحاد
السجون في اعتقاد ان هذه المبادره حتى وان
قدرت لها ان تتشكل لن يقبلها رئيس
الجمهوريه
الوزير التونسيه السابق استاذ علم
الاجتماع في الجامعه التونسيه شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى اوكرانيا حيث قال مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني اندرياس ان كيف حصلت على اشاره
ايجابيه من بولندا بشان مقاتله اف 16
وانها مستعده لنقلها الى اوكرانيا
بالتنسيق مع الناتو
قال رئيس الفرنسي ان تزويد بلاده
لاوكرانيا بالدبابات امر غير مستبعد من
جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء الهولندي ماتيوش
مرافسكي ان اي قرار بارسال طائره اف 16
الى اوكرانيا سيتم بتنسيق كامل مع دول
النيته واضافه
تتبع جميع خطوات تقويه القدرات الدفاعيه
الاخرانيه مع شركائها في الحلف وبشكل خاص
مع الولايات المتحده
لتقويه الدفاعات الاوكرانيه مع دول النيته
هذا ما فعلناه مع نظام باتريوت ومع
الدبابات كلها كانت منسقه ومتفقا عليها مع
الولايات المتحده الامر ذات وفعلناه قبل
اشهر قليله بشان طائره 29
طائره اف 16 بطريقه نفسها سنعمل بتنسيق
كامل مع الحلفاء
تلقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان اتصال هاتفيه مع الرئيس من الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين وقالت وكاله
الانباء السعوديه ان الاتصال شهيدا
استعراض العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
وبحث عدد من المسائل ذات الاهتمام المشترك
من جانبه اعلى من الكرملين لان الرئيس
بوتين وولي العهد السعودي بحث هاتفا
التعاون في اطار اوبك بلس وضمان الاستقرار
في اسواق الطاقه العالميه
ارتفع عدد قتلى التفجير الانتحاري في مسجد
في مدينه الفيشاوي الباكستانيه الى اكثر
من 60 قتيلا وعشرات الجرح
هنا باكستان فاجعه تضاف الى اخرى خلال 24
ساعه وبعد مقتل اكثر من 40 شخصا في حادث
سقوط حافله من على جسر جنوب غربي البلاد
شهدت بيشاور احدى اكثر الهجمات دمويه
انتحاري من حركه طالبان باكستان يفجر نفسه
داخل مسجد مكتظا بالمصلين ظهرا سقط
العشرات بين قتيل وجريح وانهارت اجزاء
واسعه من سقف المسجد في الطابقين بين
الركام والحطام سابقت فرق الاسعاف والسكان
الوقت للعثور على احياء ومع مرور السعاده
كشفت الفاجعه اكثر فعداد القتلى في ارتفاع
حيث يقضي بعض الضحايا متاثرين باصابتهم
بينما المصابون اضعاف ذلك وقد هرعت سيارته
الاسعاف تنقلهم الى مستشفى المدينه
الرئيسي
حاله من الهلع والارتباك على بعد اقل من
200 كم من العاصمه اسلام اباد تقع مدينه
بيشاور عاصمه اقليم بيشاور شمال غربي
باكستان على الحدود مع افغانستان المدينه
المفترضه غالبا بها مجمع امني شديد
الحراسه يحاذيه المسجد المستهدف الذي
يرتاده غالبا عناصر الشرطه الباكستانيه
وبينما تحول رئيس الوزراء الى مستشفى
بيشاور لزياره الجرحى تلاحقت مواقف القاده
السياسيين محليا ودوليا ممدده بالهجوم
الذي تبنته حركه طالبان الباكستانيه
الحركه نفسها التي تستهدف اساسا قوات
الامن كانت قد اعلنت في نوفمبر الماضي
مسؤوليتها عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص بينهم
امراه وطفل بتفجير سياره مفخخه غربيه
البلاد قرب للشرطه كانت ترافق فريقا طبيا
لتلقيح الاطفال ذلك الهجوم بدا تاكيدا على
اعلان حركه طالبان باكستان في وقت سابق من
الشهر ذاته الغاء اتفاق هش لوقف اطلاق
النار تم التوصل اليه مع الحكومه في يونيو
حزيران الماضي لكن التدهور الامني يمتد
الى ما قبل تلك الفتره اذ شنه تنظيم
الدوله في مارس اذان الماضي هجوما على
مسجد للطائفه الشيعيه في بيشاور ايضا اسفر
عن مقتل 64 شخصا في واقعه هي الاكثر
الدمويه في باكستان منذ عام 2018
[موسيقى]
من جديد تعود والعمليات الانتحاريه
والهجمات ضد افراد الامن الى الواجهه في
باكستان فما الذي حدث هو تفجير الانتحاري
في مسجد مزدحم بمدينه بيشاور شرقي او شمال
غربيه
للمناطق القبليه الباكستانيه على الحدود
مع افغانستان المسجد المستهدف يقع بالقرب
من المقر العام للشرطه
لاجراءات مشدده ويضم مباني وكالات
استخبارات مختلفه وبحسب الشرطه فقد وقع
الانفجار في الصف الثاني من المصلين وادى
هذا الانفجار الذي وقع اثناء صلاه العصر
الى تطاير سقفي وجدراني هذا المسجد
يقول رئيس شرطه بيشاور ان 300 من الى 400
شخص يؤمرون عاده هذا المسجد وهذا ما يفسر
العدد الكبير للضحايا ومعظمهم من عناصر
الشرطه بعد الهجوم وضعت العاصمه وبقيه
البلاد خصوصا المناطق الحدوديه مع
افغانستان في حاله تاهب امنيا مشدده
تعرضت في شهر التي تقع على بعد حوالي 50
كيلومترا من اسلام الحدود مع افغانستان
لها جماعه شبه يوميه خلال النصف الاول من
العقد الماضي عاد الهدوء لكن الهجمات
تجددت في الاشهر الاخيره نستعرضها
بيمارس من العام الماضي قتل 56 شخصا على
الاقل في هجوم الانتحار استهدف مسجدا
شيعيا في مدينه بيشاور شمال غربيه باكستان
وتبنه تنظيم الدوله
وفي اكتوبر عام 2020 قتل تسعه طلاب واصيب
نحو 120 اثرا انفجار عبوه ناسفه داخل
مدرسه لتحفيظ القران في مدينه بيشاور ولم
تعلن اي جهه مسؤوليتها في ديسمبر 2014 15
تطور اللافت في ديسمبر من الاعامي الماضي
حيث استولى مسلحون على مركز لمكافحه
الارهاب في شمال غربيه باكستان
واحتجزورها هنا للتفاوض مع سلطاته
الحكوميه يشير الى ان حركه طالبان باكستان
كشفت هجماتهم منذ ان انهت ما يوصف بانه
اتفاق سلام مع الحكومه الباكستانيه العام
الماضي
وهو الكاتب هو المحلل السياسي اهلا بك سيد
رفعت كيف نفهم هذا التطور في العمليات بين
طالبان باكستان من جهه وبين الحكومه
الباكستانيه ولم يوجد حد او حل لهذا
الصراع الذي طال
الديسك تاعت
هذا الهجوم
ان فرص
التفاوض مع حركه
طالبان باكستان
قبل هذا الهجوم اذا ما عدنا الى شهر
الى الوراء كان هناك هجوم في اسلام اباد
استهدف اسلام اباد العاصمه
وبعد هذا الهجوم
عقد اجتماع برئاسه رئيس مجلس الوزراء
الباكستاني
وتم اتخاذ القرار بان المفاوضات سوف تتوقف
مع حركه الطالب باكستان
اوكيبان باكستان
المفضل هو ان يتم الحديث مباشره مع طالبان
افغانستان الاماره الاسلاميه
الداعمه
لحركه طالبان باكستان ولكن الهجوم في
بشاور الذي حصل اليوم هو من بين اكبر
الهجمات التي حصلت في السنوات الماضيه
وادى الى مقتل عددا من رجال الشرطه كذلك
ما هي مطالب طالبان باكستان
تهريج بتاع البنك باكستاني
تطالب
[موسيقى]
الحريه للدخول الى باكستان
مع حمل الاسلحه
بالاضافه الى المنطقه نحن نتحدث عن
المنطقه بشكل عام هناك منطقه قضليه
بالريال زوال
هذه المنطقه القبليه ضمت الى باكستان
ولكنها كانت
حافظت على نوعا من الاستقلال الذاتي
وبالتالي حركه طالبان باكستان طلبت بعكس
هذا القرار عمليه الضم هذه تمت بعد تعديل
دستوريه ولكن حركه طالبان باكستان تطالب
بالعوده عن هذا القرار ولكن يصعب على
السلطات الباكستانيه ان تعود عن هذا
القرار القاضي بدمه تلك المنطقه القبليه
لاننا نتحدث هنا عن تعديل دستوري
والمطلب همم الاخر همم هو همم شو هذا
اسلحه بشكل اساسي
التسليح والاسلحه في داخل باكستان
لا يقبلون ان تنزع الاسلحه منهم ولكن
السلطات الباكستانيه والمؤسسات العسكريه
والامنيه الباكستانيه غير مستعده للقبول
بهذه المطالب اذا هذه هي المشاكل والمسائل
العالقه والتي ظلت عالقه في خلال
المفاوضات بين الحكومه الباكستانيه وحركه
طالبان باكستان
ورقه عسكريه
الوقت من اسلام اباد رفعت اورج زي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي
[موسيقى]
بنغادر شبه القاره الهنديه وكان عشرات
السنين لم تغير من الامر شيئا حاله الذكرى
الخامسه والسبعون اغتيال الامهات ما غاندي
بطل استقلال الهند قتل غاندي في الثلاثين
مليون من يناير من عام
1948 خلال صلاه لاديان متعدده عندما اطلق
متطرف الهندوسي يدعى نظره غوتسي النار
عليه
بالتسامح مع الاقليه المسلمه كيف يبدو
المشهد الان في الهند تسيطر على هذا البلد
وعلى قلوب الهنود حاليا البيولوجيا
الكراهيه البيولوجيه الاستقطاب اديولوجيه
الانقسام هذا ما يقوله الكاتب
تشارك غاندي احد اشهر احفاد المهاتما
غاندي ايقونه ويقول تشاهد ان اراء كوتسي
قاتل لجده تكتسب زخما متزايدا وتتراجع
افكار غاندي والامل كل الامل ان تسود في
عالمنا قيم الصدق والمساواه والوحده
والاندماج التي تتصدر ارثا الفقيد
المهاتما غاندي دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]